we're in the middle of summer and we are  already knee-deep in live-action movies  based on beloved characters from our  childhood you got transformers Captain  America Smurfs movie coming out soon  enough about that oh yeah but I think I  think Hollywood is starting to run out I  think they're starting to scrape the  bottom of the barrel for characters to  make movies about check out this trailer  I just saw last night when justice runs  thin only one woman has what it takes to  pour it on sick  [Music]  on a mission of vengeance she's about to  turn the battlefield into a parking fee  against the greatest forces of evil ever  assembled  on august 39  yes bull  you're crazy now I'm awesome  [Applause]